yeah this is no obviously yes no things
are a little tough for Lex Luthor at the
moment but he's but he's a tough guy
yeah yeah you look like you're having a
lot of fun like watching the episodes
that you mature in since you premiere
like it must be a blast to do oh
absolutely absolutely this III have the
only other comic book movie I ever did
was Superman for way back in the day and
and it's always just an incredibly
joyful experience cuz I loved him as a
kid and I absolutely loved him I loved
the characters and that I get to do Lex
Luthor is you know just this amazing
honor so you know it was a little scary
frankly at the beginning but but I I
don't know there's just a little there's
a lot of him in me so I was like okay I
can do this there's a lot of him in you
disturbing and actually well because
he's just so he's he's he's a total
narcissist and and he he he he thinks
he's the smartest person in the room the
thing is that he actually is that Lex
actually is and that's where I fall
short but but I don't know it's it's
it's been an incredibly natural fit for
me and I know a lot of people were you
know frankly dubious of the guy from Two
and a Half Men when playing Lex Luthor
but but I get it I've been I was I was
skeptical too frankly but the but like
five minutes after they talked to me
about it I say oh no there's there's no
way I am NOT doing this
yeah like was what was the hesitation on
your part about when they talk to you
about it initially just because the
character is an icon yeah you know it's
a it's an iconic character it's
something that a lot of people would be
excited about seeing and I don't let him
down mm-hmm and and it was a character I
loved you know that's why I did Superman
for so but what we realized was that we
actually had had an opportunity to do a
Lex Luthor that was much closer to the
comic books then has ever been done
before and that became apparent like
halfway through the first episode of
shooting and we were all just kind of
gleeful we like we're gonna get a
with this aren't we and and it's just
been joyful all the time the cool thing
for fans that watch the show is that the
Devils in the details so it's like you
know immediately we see like the suit
you know you get the powers like it's
very cool what you're able to do right
off the bat and that must have been a
thrill oh yeah absolutely and that that
Lex Luthor finally gets to wear his war
suit yeah is you know that's been a
thrill for a lot of the fans and for me
frankly because I've never done I've
never been Iron Man I've never done a
big special effects movie and so to be
to see first of all it's different now
than when I back in the day I mean when
I did Superman for ya we had to do a
scene where Superman flies underneath
our car me and Lex Luthor my my evil
uncle and flies away with us now
nowadays they would do that on a green
screen you you there might be a car
there might not even be a car you know
or they would just do a motion capture
of your body and put it in a car and put
it in you wouldn't not in any way touch
that situation back then they took a car
wired it to a crane a construction crane
put Gene Hackman and me in it yeah and
then wired Christopher Reeve underneath
it with these huge fans to blow his cape
and then they just flew it away so
things have changed and now you get to
throw like The Daily Planet globe yes
and yeah are you Loki talking to the
writers about trying to bring lenny
actually you're not wrong we've been
talking about casting but but yeah i
think what they're enjoying a lot about
this version of Lex is he's actually
scary yeah they're actually letting me
make him be a sociopath and a really
dangerous character because in a lot of
the movies is it you know like the
Donner movie is where he it was played a
little more comedic Lee and you know we
have a few of those little moments but
but this guy's lethal yeah
and that's been really a really a fun
opportunity
was it a challenge for you at all
stepping into this family I mean this
cast has been together for so long you
know introducing you to you as Lex into
this whole world for the show kind of up
ends everything in the storyline what
was it like coming onto the set as you
know they're super mean and very remote
and don't speak with people
no they're just incredibly lovely and
warm and I my the craziest thing like
like Brenda strong who plays lily and
Luther my mother I you know had never
met her before so I was walking my dog
one day and I round a corner and I
gasped because this other woman there
gasped at me and it was Brenda strong
walking her dog turns out we're
neighbors we're live like a block and a
half from each other but it's been that
sort of wonderful bunch of coincidences
with everybody has just been really a
they're very happy group of people yeah
and they all really love the show
they're doing and so they were just
excited that someone was bringing the
drama you know and giving them something
fun to build up to the finale well we
get to see more of Lex moving on I don't
know it is it is I don't I don't
the the I know DC Comics and you know
they're very proprietary about the
they're more iconic characters and and
they don't want them you know they they
want to keep it and make make sure it's
special when they show up and I
understand that and the same thing with
the Warner Brothers and the movies and
all that stuff but that being said we've
clearly caught lightning in a bottle
with the character I was absolutely
bowled over by the reaction from the fan
community and and I haven't been a
member of that community it was like
doubly satisfying so you know I like I
said I think we have an opportunity here
to to really make the Lex that's been
living in the comics for all this time
and come to life and I hope they'll give
us more opportunities to it you know I
understand if they don't but but it's
been it's been grateful in so fanatical
adavi I
a fan you know you must have this
thought in your head you know I'm
Supergirl we've seen crossovers with
other Everest shows and other characters
current kind of being introduced what
would you like to see as another
crossover moving forward in Supergirl Oh
in Supergirl
yeah well gosh I don't know you know I I
know they're doing a big event yeah with
crisis on Infinite Earths with Lex is in
by the way not gonna hit but he's in the
comic book I don't know if it'll make it
to the to the to their version but but
the you know I I'm excited about that
because that because all bets are off
yeah after that I mean just the whole
the whole universe is going to be
changed and so they so all the shows
have an opportunity to do reboot and
restart and so I don't know I I would
you know I'd love for the Teen Titans to
be in there I'd love for the I love you
know there's a the we could absolutely
have more of the the flash characters we
couldn't I mean if that possibilities
are endless right now I know you can't
say anything about the final episode of
course but if you can describe it in
four words what four words would you use
oh gosh
[Music]
[Laughter]
Lex worse than you thought but now
that's five it's just that I have to say
even I was surprised yeah at Lex's big
evil plan yeah because it has not yet
been revealed and when it is it's really
evil so I I have to say I was turning
the page going oh oh my goodness he's
really he's going there okay so yeah
it's a it they they they paid off
everything they've been setting up
you